not knowing those Elementary skills
though that can be a huge impediment I
had people in my clinical practice we
spent hours practicing how to introduce
them and to shake hands cuz you want to
be expert at that because if you're not
good at that at all you're screwed you
can't even tell someone your name and so
how are you going to make a friend then
you announce yourself as incompetent
with your first move if that happens to
you 10 times you're so terrified
disincentivized oh God terribly that's
something you can do with your kids is
so they can become expert at introducing
themselves shake hands do it with a bit
of a firm grip look the other person try
smiling match your Tempo to the other
person